i
this is unbelievable uh so whoever uh
so you're i i just learned that yfn
means your friendly
neighborhood right okay uh hackers
so uh and look we brought it with us
unbelievable
this is making my day this is making my
week this is incredible
and uh and i really i i i don't know
what to say
uh this is amazing so so whoever you are
thank you
this is this is awesome so like
you know uh
where's laura so laura uh next year
i think we should give every student one
of these
right this will be in our in our so
we've got some candy
we've got t-shirts um we'll get to those
um we've got welcome to the last lecture
oh there's some t-shirts we're gonna let
tas throw them out
we're gonna let ta throw them out um and
uh
and and but but uh
we're getting yeah
you guys gotta uh now um
so we got a little bit more to cover
um on diffusion i got my
i gotta why this matters and then i got
a couple things i want to say
um and and then we'll conclude and like
i said uh
the plan today is to conclude a little
early
to give you time to fill out the course
evaluations
we really take this seriously we really
value
uh any and all input that you have
um and and so please do if you haven't
done it already please use the last
15 minutes that we'll give you in the
class to fill those out
um it means a lot to us um
okay i i kind of can't this is still
uh it's hitting me right here it's
slowing me down
okay i'm gonna get i can do it i'm gonna
get through it
so we were talking about fixed laws and
uh
and you're only going to be tested on
the first one okay
but i do want to tell you about the
second one um
you are not going to be tested on the
second one that is correct
unlike last year this year because we
didn't have time
to get the lecture in on the second law
before the recitation which was
yesterday and so
look you'll there'll probably be a
diffusion problem
um but uh but not on the second law but
i still
i do want to finish the example um and i
won't go through it in detail but i want
to set it up and just show it to you so
you have a sense of
what fixed second log lets you do
um and we you know we ended with the
first law and i wrote the second law
down now the first law
that is something i want you to know
about and so remember you know
with the first law so if we're uh let me
go over here
so you have a whole board to my to use
so in
in fixed first law uh what that meant
was
it's it's a law that describes uh
the steady state so um fixed first law
was steady state and and this is now you
know this is now bringing back
memories from two days ago so steady
state which means
uh no time
dependence no time
dependence okay and so we had you know
some examples of that and
the law itself i'll write it down here
was that the flux
um is equal to minus this diffusion
constant times the change in
concentration
over some difference over some distance
over some distance and and so we had
this example
of um of a membrane right and so so you
could imagine like some
you know we had the glove right it was
the remember the butyl glove
and and so we had some distance maybe
this is like a
a delta x and and there was some
concentration up here
right c one and some concentration down
here c2
and now in the key in fixed laws you're
going to hold these concentrations
constant
at the source right at each of these
points and so
you can imagine that it's going to
change as you go down the hill and we
frame this
in terms of brownian motion now you're
able to understand
why concentration why diffusion happens
down a concentration gradient right
and uh and so and that gets and now that
that flux
that flux right remember so j is uh
j is an amount
divided by an area times time
right that's j that's the flux through
the membrane
and that is uh also going to be uh
constant now the the d
what we assumed in the d is that
it's a constant so in the fixed first
law of problems we often assume d
doesn't depend on concentration right
so that means that if i'm over here at a
high concentration i'm at
over here at a low concentration well
then
by the way this would be like
you like some candy i would like some
candy thank you very much
up and down not at all no yeah that's
awesome
okay
okay
i uh
this is just getting better i'm feeling
less and less like talking about fixed
law
but but here we are i'll go fast
but okay now uh
now the thing is you know look
um so this this is x
this is x um i by the way i really want
to know where they got the
the costumes um from but this is x and
this would be like the concentration
right
and um and now d okay
look d could depend on concentration by
the way
it's actually quite interesting it does
have a small dependence on concentration
we often don't don't include it so this
would be like a straight line
you know but if it did if it did depend
on concentration
then you might have a deviation right
you could have something like this
right you could have something like that
you don't need to have a straight line
to use fixed law but in a lot of the
problems that we do we assume
d is just independent of concentration
it's a constant
right i mean if it did depend you know
so i'm adding more and more
carbon and iron does the diffusion of
the carbon now depend on how much i
added
well yeah it might a little bit by the
way that doesn't mean that it depends on
time
that's the distinction i want to make
right so again
you know in the problems we do with
fixed law we'll assume d
doesn't depend on concentration we'll
just assume it's a constant but the main
determining factor to see if it's a
fixed second law or a fixed first law
problem
isn't whether d changes with
concentration no
it's whether there's a time dependence
it's whether there's a time dependence
and that was the problem that we left
off on
on um on monday
right we say well you got to do this
thing called case hardening to a lot of
materials you make the outside harder
the inside has to stay ductile otherwise
either it's not strong enough
or it's it's too ductile right it just
breaks down either way
or it's too brittle so you want to case
harden and that was our fixed second law
problem and and and again i'm just going
to kind of
set it up i'm not going to go through it
all but in the in the second law
in the second law what you have is an
ability
now to look at the time dependence so
you can imagine
if i have position x and concentration
c and i start somewhere here so i have
some
some source that's why we call it cs
right
so what did we do we took this piece of
steel and we asked a question
right i've got i've got i'm case
hardening the steel so this is iron with
carbon
and i and i want to put carbon into it
but only up to a certain point
right in a certain a certain amount how
do i know how long to put it in the oven
that's a fixed second law problem
because it's a time dependent process
and i want to know about concentrations
into the piece of iron into the piece of
steel as a function of time so you can
answer questions like this with fixed
second law
so i had it at 0.25 weight percent
carbon
and i carburized the surface i
carborized only a certain amount of it
i case harden it right how long should
you keep it in the oven
and and by the way also like how much
what should your carbon
your concentration of source be on the
outside
right and all these things kind of go in
and and so you could imagine if the
source is there and i'm holding
maybe i've got some constant c naught
right that's the point too that's the
piece of material i started with
right then well you can imagine at t
zero
you've got you've got this so this would
be like time
equals t naught and then as soon as i
expose this to this uh this higher
concentration of carbon
you might have something like this so
now you've got t1
and now i wait a little bit longer and
it's going to be able to penetrate
more in so the concentration inside the
material changes
as a function of time and so forth
right that's what fixed second law tells
us and it's
the the second law is basically a heat
equation
which somebody uh noticed after a
lecture yesterday
and you know you can um
uh let's see dx squared so this is a
this is a partial differential equation
and um and but but solving it is
is just is just you know talking to our
mathematician friends
right and they come back and say oh
that's an error function
and an error function is just a function
and it gives us a solution
c the concentration at any position and
at any time
minus the initial concentration divided
by this
difference in concentrations between the
source and the initial
is going to equal oh boy
you'd think i'd have learned 36 lectures
and i still worked my way into a corner
i'm going to do the equals this way 1
minus
error function of x
over 2 root d
t that
is what you get
when you solve fixed second law
that is what you get when you solve
fixed second law
and um and now the error function is
just a function
it's not you know you don't need to
worry about uh
about the details of this you can think
about it as any as like any other
function
and but one thing that i want to share
with you about the error function
is and this is something that yeah
you're not going to need it
on on the exam but you might need this
in life
you might get an error function in life
and earth and if you get an earth
i don't want you to panic because an
earth is just a function and it just
looks like this okay it just looks like
it's a linear plot roughly
up to about 0.6 this trick and then
it kind of goes up to one right
it's just a function is that one yeah
and and so if it's if z is less than
than 0.6
then the error function of z is roughly
z talk about a valuable
thing to learn and that saves you a lot
of time
by the way yeah but but it's just a
function and it's it's a solution
to fix second law so again this is this
is uh
uh this is how we solve time dependent
diffusion problems and this is how you
could solve this one right here
and what i'm gonna do is i'm not going
to actually solve it
i'm going to give you the answer to
that question so the time
is seven hours
that's the answer and i'm also going to
leave you with the with oh there's error
function tables oh
look at that error function tables and
and
there's the setup of the problem so i'm
going to leave you actually with the
sketch of the setup
and again you know this isn't something
we'll have on the exam but i want you to
have this kind of problem at your
at your at your service
right so you would have this these are
all embedded in the question there's
your cs
there's your c naught right at this
distance this is what the question
asks this is the concentration we want
we know we look up the diffusion of
carbon
we assume it's not dependent on
concentration
that d and so we just use a constant and
then we plug it in
and we get a time you better believe
that this is really important
this is really really important this is
how we make stuff
this is how we make stuff that we make
our world out of
right and and so so that's the picture i
showed you
all right and this gets me now to oh
our last why this matters right
do i need them all i and i'm doing it on
the backdrop of this beautiful periodic
table
right so so
that's a lot of energy by the way
you know first you had to make these
iron pipes and now you gotta you gotta
case harden them
right or maybe you gotta put even more
iron in
look at the oven 900c is really hot
how much energy do we take to make stuff
as simple as
as concrete right doesn't it just liquid
stone
didn't you just grind some stones down
or something and then pour it out
right actually if you think about
concrete and other materials like steel
right the use of them is going is
skyrocketing
right this is how much we're making okay
so this uh
so look at this the millions of tons um
there's
uh let's see there's steel and there's
cement
look at that there's the world
population right there and this only
runs out this runs out in 29 2010
11 but it's continuing
it's continuing because
because it's not just that the
population is growing it's that the
places that the population is growing
the most are also
industrializing and that means
building you go to some of these places
and there's a new building literally
every block
there's a new building being built that
takes
that takes this stuff that takes a lot
of
ovens and a lot of really high
temperatures
the the just the cement alone
is is accounting for seven percent
of all co2 emissions all co2 emissions
on the planet
seven percent of that goes into simply
making this liquid
this magic liquid stone this powder
and at the core of it what is at the
core of it it's chemistry
it's clinker it's called a clinker what
is a clinker it's this thing
it's simply a calcium silicate group
making that is what takes all this
energy it takes half of it at least
making that right
and and it's it's as always the
chemistry gives us
the the chance to get out of our
constrained optimization
right and so so you've got to make this
mixture of
of different types of synthetic rock
you've got to make mixtures of allied
and ballet they have different names
and and and you might be able to make
more bellite which takes less energy you
can you can cool your oven down by 300 c
to make bellite
compared to allied yeah but then
even though it's structurally okay it
takes 90 days to dry
so you can't do that so you got to spend
the 300 extra uh
celsius to make more allied why
it's all the count it's in the chemistry
right
it's in the chemistry and and and
understanding
what seems like not a very interesting
you know cement is it really that
interesting you bet it is
seven percent of all co2 emissions it's
just making this one material
and we're making a lot of it we're
making a lot of it there's a tower 164
tower
in dubai that opened in 2010 that took a
billion
kilograms of this stuff right
so um now this makes a lot of co2 and
i've talked about co2 throughout the
semester right and and so
so one thing i wanted to leave you with
was also some things that we're doing
about it what do we do about co2
so how is carbon capture and
sequestration going
right could we take it all out we put it
in could we take it out
um and so i'll share a couple of things
so
you know one of the problems with co2
capture is that if you don't do it right
where
you make it then you have to transport
it and it turns out that's actually
really it's really hard to transport co2
and there's a lot of problems that have
happened over the years in the 80s uh
there was a leak that killed thousands
of people um there have been
massive leaks in in canada in
transporting this material
so transporting is actually really hard
to do um
there's metal pipe corrosion this is a
great chemistry problem
unsolved um and and then
the next part of co2 sequestration so
one is transporting it that's
challenging and the other is storing it
what do you do with it
let's suppose we could capture it well
then what
and and there's there's ideas around
this right so you could pump it maybe
underground
geosequestration maybe that that that's
that's not a sure thing we don't know we
don't understand
at those scales exactly how well we can
encase this material and how long it
will last
there's a lot of questions with that
there's a whole line of thinking
on putting it in the ocean
right really so so you want to
fix the co2 problem by by acidifying the
oceans even faster
okay interesting right
um um so so so so transport and
sequestration is is a big problem
but what about technologies where you
simply sequester it right there
where you make it like clean coal
right you might have heard of clean coal
right so clean coal so
so i'm going to look at a case study of
a clean coal project in the u.s
in 2005 i got really excited because
eight companies joined and it was called
futuregen and the us government
was going to put a lot of money into it
they were going to capture 90
of the co2 you get a little bit less
efficiency depending on how you think
about it it could be 30 percent less
efficiency i mean less power out of the
plant
but you sequester the co2 and
in 2009 construction was planned in
illinois in 2010 it was canceled in 2010
it was restarted in 2012 um
there was all sorts of uh of discussions
with the doe that agreed to pay 1.1
billion dollars it was all located and
then the companies dropped out and the
doe canceled the project so that was 10
years
10 years and 200 million dollars of
taxpayer dollars and absolutely nothing
has come out of it
um so so one of the you know the things
i want to point out about this
direction and i'm not saying that it's
it's not a good direction to keep
pursuing but the time scales are long
so we need to be able to make decisions
that can cover longer time scales
that's a huge part of the challenge with
this it's a policy challenge as much as
it is
a technical one um
there is and tying this back to the
cement
um there is some really interesting
research
that's going on in actually instead of
okay so you've got the co2 it comes out
when you make it because the ovens and
you're burning stuff and
and but what if you could take that co2
and just put it into the thing you're
making
and and by the way if you're if what
you're making is a huge scale like
cement
then maybe you could put a lot of it in
right and maybe that could have a real
global impact
so there's a lot of interest in uh
substantial okay so here substantial
global carbon uptake by cement
carbonation
so maybe you could get some of it in the
cement i like this paper i'm pointing it
out because
they say that they use fixed diffusion
law
they modeled the carbon uptake by
applying fixed diffusion law
yeah it actually matters
right you can do this too now
and just a few weeks ago on cnn there
was no this concrete yes concrete
is going high-tech why because this
company
has managed to figure out how to put a
bunch of co2 into the concrete while
they make it
and it doesn't change the mechanical
integrity of the concrete
and it's in there it's actually in there
right
this is all chemistry this is all
chemistry so this is i think another
very interesting direction uh where
technology can play a vital role in in
this particular
global challenge okay and now
oh i'm putting the chalk down
and i come to the conclusion i can't
look there i'm going to get sad
you're making me i
the first thing about this that i got to
do
is i got to think i got to thank people
at first i got to thank the concepts
you got to thank the material this is
what we have talked about all semester
this is what we have learned this
is this is underneath the hood
of so much and i hope that i've conveyed
that to you
this is a starting point for so much
right what have we learned well we've
learned how to go back and forth this is
what i showed you on day one and now
what have we done
we have filled this out we filled it out
with balancing reactions we filled it
out with the periodic table that one
we filled it out with electrons bore
model schrodinger atomic orbitals
molecular orbitals
ionic solids lewis dots vesper van der
waals london h-bonds all sorts of
intermolecular forces
metallic bonds semiconductors bands
crystal symmetry lattices planes
x-rays x-ray diffraction defects
amorphous glassy materials
reaction rates rate laws diffusion
solubility uranius acids and bases
polymers and their properties
that's you guys
that's you guys that have learned that
material
i it blows me away that's a lot of stuff
and we've learned it all and we've we've
we've integrated it
into our lives but you couldn't have
learned any of this we couldn't have
done
any of this without some people
so now we thank the subjects we thank
the people laura
would you stand up please because
many of you have interacted with laura
and you know and now sometimes you might
get a short answer
you might get a not a short answer
because
but why is that it's because laura cares
deeply deeply about you all and about
your
learning and your experience in this
class and at mit she cares deeply
and that's the kind of thing that makes
this class what it is we wouldn't have
any shot at it without laura um so laura
thank you
uh very much you know it's sort of like
there's like when you drop your kids off
at if they go to sleep way camp there's
like the camp parent
you know who makes sure that your kids
it's like they make sure that your kids
will you know brush their teeth get to
bed
uh have a plate you know have a blanket
and and they check in on your kids all
the time
and i feel like you know we have that
for this class
it's laura so thank you laura but now
okay now the thing is now the other now
i introduce these people to you
isaac i still don't have your picture
but um
can the tas please stand up can the ta
stand up come on
thank you
thank you thank you
i am so incredibly lucky
to have this quality people this quality
of staff these
these kind caring passionate amazing
people
as our tas for this class and and i have
i have
i am so lucky i get to meet with them
every week
to talk about you guys
it's always good don't worry it's always
good
um and and interact even much more than
that about education about teaching
about how to make this
uh a fantastic experience for all of you
so thanks to the tas and then that's why
i want the tas
to um to throw the t-shirts out and
we'll do that in a minute
um what a couple minutes no i one yeah
and uh but now okay but see it's the tas
that have been here for you
but it's also you all there's you so
right oh it's you all that have been
here
for each other and so and so i i see it
because i talk to some of you i don't
talk to all of you but i see the
community
that forms and i am very appreciative
that and i'd like you to be appreciate
that so let's thank each other here
for just a minute it's really pretty i
this is actually getting me revved up a
little bit
okay now i skipped over i wanna that the
goodie bags are amazing
and so i'm thankful to the goody bags
and to the department
if anyone's hearing from the department
for helping us support these goodie bags
thank you thank you
okay yeah thank you yeah that's good
okay so so i'm i'm very grateful uh to
that
i'm grateful to all of you and and you
know last um
but not i guess just last
i am thankful to harvard i was going to
say something else but um
anyway i'm thankful to all of these uh
resources
that we have used
um and and now
okay so i'm i'm gonna give you some
some closing comments i started this
semester off in the first lecture
and um and i asked you all a question
and the question was why are you here
right
i said like you know really really
really why are you here
why did you come to mit and i asked you
you know
did you come here so you can just phone
it in
get a stamp in four years and go out
right did you come here so you can walk
around some place of privilege and look
down on other people
that is not why you're here that is not
why you came to mit
right you came to mit because
you know that this is where we will make
the transition
from being able to answer any question
to knowing which question to ask
that's the transition from student to
scholar and and you know
that you came here because you have a
passion
and and you want to come to a place
where you can take that passion
and you can try to solve really hard
problems together
to make the world a better place those
are reasons why you came here you came
here because
you know that progress does not
happen because of success it doesn't
it happens entirely because of what you
choose to do with failure
that's mit that's the mit way
and that's why you're here and i asked
you to think about that on the first
lecture
and then i i gave you a whole lot of
examples throughout the class i tried to
connect our learning in solid state
chemistry
to global challenges right to global
challenges that we face
and um and i tried to do that you know
so i had 36 opportunities there's many
more
so i had to pick and choose carefully
try to try to give you a sense of some
of these things
um and and and the thing is about these
challenges
the one i just talked about and many
others these are not
you know it's not that these are things
that we need to do
soon there there is
an urgency of now about these things
there is an urgency of now
there's no more time to talk about it
right um and and so and and these
challenges you know they're also not
it's not because it happens over here
it happens over there these are
planetary
challenges these cover the whole thing
so it's
you know it's all on the table right
it's all on the line and by the way if
it's a planetary challenge it means
the challenge doesn't care if you're in
a blue state or a red state
or if you live in europe or africa or
here
it doesn't care so we better figure out
how to get our act together and work
together
to solve these very hard problems and
that's why you're here
right that's why you're here and so
you know on the first lecture i asked
you to think about why you're here and
on
you know in this very last lecture i'm
asking you
to think about what you want to do about
that what do you want to do about that
and um and you know there's a lot of
things you can do
i don't mean that that you have to work
on one of these things we've talked
about in this class that's not what i
mean i mean
think about what it is that you really
want to do and how you want to do it
and then go for it right um
you might have figured that out before
you came here you may
know because in tight already way before
you got here
you may be figuring it out right now you
may
have no clue what you want to do when
you graduate
all of those are fine all of those are
fine
yeah but but what i want to leave you
with
is a framework and some thinking that i
can
what can i leave you with as as a
suggestion as a framework
and it really comes down to three
ingredients three ingredients that i'm
asking you to think about
when you go off and do when you leave
here when you go off and do
what are you gonna do how are you gonna
frame this and and so
the first ingredient is kindness
now okay bear with me because you're all
thinking
what is he talking about this is a
chemistry class
and you're talking about kindness
and and you know but see the thing is
i'm trying to think about what is a
framework that if you
follow it you will do good
you will help change this world for the
better which is what we do at mit
it's how we think and and the thing is i
don't care if you define kindness as
love or
as helping someone or as
community or as you know on one of those
dates when the candle was in the room
and you did the calculation and you
saved the day
because you knew oxygen was going to run
out that's all kindness
all of that is kindness but the thing is
that if you have kindness in what you do
it's really hard to do bad
right is that is that under the hood
is there an element of kindness you
can't have too much of it
we need that vector right we need that
vector in this world
so that's one ingredient and the second
ingredient is knowledge now what i mean
by this is acquisition of knowledge
and we have done a lot of that here in
this class and you do a lot of that at
mit and we celebrate these acquisitions
what i'm asking you to do is think about
this as you go forward
how are you acquiring knowledge how are
you learning
that sounds cliche you always learn you
guys have to keep doing that
you have to keep doing that because for
you it's nourishment
and it's another one of these vectors
you can't do any harm
by learning you can only do good for
yourself and for everyone
that you care about so keep doing it
the rate might change if learning
acquisition is a reaction
the rate constant might be lower we know
places where that's already the case
and and that's okay
maybe the order is lower too down there
and and the
but i think you know they probably are
learning something
keep keep that going and the last thing
is passion
and this involves your talents right
you all have talents already you all
have them
because that's part of who you are and
why you're here
those are things that you bring a
passion to what are those talents
maybe some of them are hidden but work
on them and pursue them
do things that you literally are so
excited about you can't sleep sometimes
because of the excitement
that's what i'm talking about follow
that
feed it and while you do
you know lose lose the fear
right avoid greed and embrace challenge
that's what that's what mit is that's
why we're here
right that's why we're here so so i i
feel like these three ingredients you
know i've thought about this and i've
thought about these three ingredients
and i've thought about
we have these already you all have
these ingredients because that is also
mit
and you are here and you are mit
and so what i'm asking you to do is to
hold on to them
and keep thinking about that
that's it there's a lot of reasons why i
love to teach
and but but but one of the big ones is
when i think about
the challenges that i share with you
guys
and and i have 36 chances to look up in
the room
and i think about those challenges and i
think about these ingredients and i
think about
all of you i actually feel like we have
a shot
i actually feel that and so so with that
good luck on the final and have a
fantastic break
thank you so much thank you thank you
guys
thank you guys thank you thank you
thank you so much thank you
you guys are amazing
thank you thank you
thank you all so much i i i'm gonna have
to leave here or i'm gonna get
really emotional i've also i've clearly
got a lot of other dance moves the tas
have
have uh have helped me so i can practice
those
uh thank you so much that that's just
incredible
uh you guys are all incredible and this
has been incredible so
um uh we do have uh ten minutes uh
they're gonna throw i'm gonna leave so
you guys can fill evaluations out
without me being in the room
and uh and and so you can say whatever
you want
um again don't let the free t-shirts be
being thrown at you
influence your opinion or the free candy
but uh but thanks everyone for a
fantastic semester
thank you
that was amazing you guys
you